back in 2004 a little film called
napoleon dynamite became not just a cult
classic but a cultural touchstone
where did star john heder vanish to
following the success of napoleon
dynamite heda acted in some films you
may have seen
in 2005's just like heaven he played
opposite mark ruffalo and rhys
witherspoon
as a psychic bookstore clerk in 2006's
the bench warmers he played clark
one of the nerds who made up a baseball
team that represents all the people who
normally get bullied because they have
no athletic skill
and in 2007's blades of glory he worked
alongside will ferrell as a washed up
skater kicked out of the 2002 olympics
in an interview with the tufts daily
heda said i really enjoy physical comedy
kind of turning your body into a cartoon
i just love
bringing characters to life whether it
be through the words or through their
movement and being
you can get so much about a character
through the way they position themselves
or the way they move
almost every role i've done i love
getting like extreme costumes and hair
and makeup and
looking different in every single one
after that
hedo played one of a series of suitors
trying to win the attention of kristen
bell's character
in the 2009 film when in rome since 2010
we bet you can't name anything you've
seen john heder in
in 2012 he starred in a short-lived
napoleon dynamite animated television
series
which lasted for six episodes his
subsequent movie roles included parts
and forgettable films like 2012's for
ellen
2016's ghost team and 2020's tremors
shrika island the seventh installment in
the tremors franchise
he's appeared in a number of web series
video shorts
and independent movies including when
jeff tried to save the world
this was a project made by first time
filmmaker kendall goldberg
speaking about why he decided to take on
a movie from a novice creator
he'd told third coast review i want that
passion and excitement
first time directors have so much to
prove and that energy
focused correctly can really benefit the
production i felt that for sure on this
film when i went into the audition and
saw kendall
i didn't know who it was but she looked
like a college student
and she was at the time heda continued i
was impressed by the script and we sat
and talked and it was clear she knew
what she was doing
and she has a vision and intense focus
so i could feel that this would be a fun
project
to be a part of based on this it sounds
like hida might have made a conscious
choice to focus on smaller productions
as a way of reconnecting with his love
of performing on the other hand this
could also be a way of spinning the fact
that he could no longer command the
types of roles he once did
don't cry fajita he might not be seen in
high-profile feature films anymore but
he's definitely made a name for himself
elsewhere
and that may always have been a part of
the plan in a 2004 interview with sag
indy he pointed out that he graduated
from brigham young in animation
and had moved to los angeles to continue
his acting and animation career
he said he started getting the acting
bug as a teenager making videos
and at college he was attracted to
animation because of the way it melts
art and film
not long after in 2005 he was part of
cartoon network's robot chicken
and that role may have opened quite a
few doors for him in the voice acting
realm
because his voiceover career has been
robust since then he's considered a
versatile voice actor
and you may have heard him in movies
like 2006's monster house and surf's up
not to mention surf sub 2 the
direct-to-video sequel released in 2016.
in those films he played surfer penguin
chicken joe over on the tv side of
things
his voice can be heard guest starring in
animated television series
such as uncle grandpa ben 10 omniverse
tales of the teenage mutant ninja
turtles
the legend of korra and star vs the
forces of evil
he's also voiced a few video games
including epic mickey 2 the power of two
given that he said in the past that his
part in the industry might be best
described
as the underdog voiceover work
definitely suits him
if you check out hida's social media
accounts you'll see he's never truly
disappeared
he posts both professional and personal
news on his instagram account
including pictures of his wife and four
children he and wife kirsten met in
college and married in 2002
before he found fame with napoleon
dynamite their parents to daughter evan
sons philip and timothy and a second
daughter born in december 2016
whose name doesn't appear to have been
revealed to the public yet
it's pretty likely he and his wife have
their hands full with family life
on an episode of the world's best dad
podcast he'd talked about his boy scout
leader experience and family life
including growing up with his identical
twin brother he said
my life is i'm home a lot i'm home a
turn if i'm not working
and then sometimes when i am working i'm
gone for three or four days or a couple
of weeks
but more often than not i'm home so my
bonding time is every day with the kids
so i just stay indoors all day hedo has
turned down roles drawing his career for
numerous reasons
including the fact that as a famous
person he feels like an
official ambassador for his religion the
church of jesus christ of latter-day
saints
as a result he has an aversion to scenes
involving sex and violence
preferring clean content instead he told
the south florida sun sentinel in 2006
i don't think i ever will do a sex scene
because of my religion and my personal
standards
i won't show the act of it on screen i'd
do a violent scene if it was in a war
film or the content or story justified
it
in a discussion of his career on reddit
one user alleged to adam sandler who
produced the benchwarmers went about
tanking hida's career
because he refused to act in another
movie of sandler's due to content
concerns
hedo's desire to stick to his principles
could very well have affected his career
choices in hollywood
still according to celebrity net worth
hida is worth 50 million dollars
so he can pick and choose his projects
going forward
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]
you